вітаємо вас у програмі Європа У фокусі
цього тижня з вами я Ліз
шум жорстокій війні в Україні не видно
кінця не минає і дня без російських
атак найсмертоносніша Атака цього року
сталася на початку жовтня в селі Гроза
на сході
України ракета влучила в кафе де жителі
зібралися після похорону загинуло понад
50 людей серед них одна
дитина
мільйони українців покинули свої домівки
із початку війни Але не всі можуть або
хочуть це робити
Ліза і Ліза підлітки чиї сім'ї вирішили
залишитися у
кураховому незважаючи на те що село
знаходиться у притул до лінії фронту наш
кореспондент зустрівся з дітьми які
ростуть у зоні досяжності російської
артилерії і для яких звук сирен став
частиною повсякденного
життя
ніхто не знає звідки взявся Геннадій
Одного дня він з'явився перед крамницею
тітки Тані Де люблять проводити час дві
Лізи Цей пес поводиться не завжди добре
каже молодша Ліза вона розповідає що
багато її друзів виїхали з містечка
Курахове що поблизу лінії фронту але
вона та її батьки
залишилися у перші дні війни було Ну як
було чутно але зараз нормально зараз уже
звикли адаптувалися гуляємо щодня у них
багато вільного часу їхню школу закрили
після повномасштабного вторгнення Росії
в Україну у лютому 2022 року зараз
російські війська знаходяться Всього за
16 км на відстані артилерійського вогню
коли продавчиня Тані відлучається Вона
залишає дівчат наглядати за магазином на
випадок якщо комусь щось знадобиться
залишилося не так багато магазинів які
працюють шкільні друзі дівчат
роз'їхалися по всій Україні та Європі
заняття проводяться тільки онлайн у нас
может быть урок у нас може урок тривати
хвилин таке дуже рідко буває а в
основному 10 Ну може 15-25 хвилин якось
так уроки балету не проводять за те
книжок стало більше ніж
раніше
письменник який став солдатом і зараз
перебуває тут попросив про пожертви з
усієї
України щоб він міг створити молодіжну
бібліотеку на
фронті Сама ідея дуже хороша Просто якщо
ти вже почав то треба довести це до
кінця Ось у чому проблема
виходить з Україною у серці написав
хтось на коробці і ви наша Надія і
натхнення прийшли десятки посилок Таня
не знає що з ними робити тому віддає
книги
владі письменник який став солдатом
пообіцяв зайнятися усім цим коли
повернеться із
відпустки ніхто вже не здригається коли
вмикаються сирени каже Ліза усі гуляють
тобто на повітряну тривогу навіть ніхто
не звертає уваги звісно коли дуже гучно
прилітає то біжимо по домівкам але нас
вистачає ненадовго буквально хвилин
10-15 і ми одразу вилітаємо
дівчата намагаються максимально
використати теплу погоду і побути на
свіжому
повітрі але вони знають що може статися
що завгодно наприклад вибух
артилерійського снаряда і тому батьки
взяли з них обіцянку не відходити далеко
від дому про всяк
випадок дівчата ведуть нас до хлопців
які гуляють за кілька кварталів звідси
вони знайшли свій спосіб згаяти час
[музика]
ми зупиняємо машини військових питаємо
пароль Тимофій і його друзі кажуть що
їхнє завдання стежити щоб ніхто з росіян
не пройшов вони показують нам нашивки
українських військових які солдати дають
їм замін
іноді їм навіть дають
солодощі якщо щось дають то дають якщо
ні то просто проїжджають і
все хлопці готуються зустрічати наступну
машину это
[музика]
кам
цього разу все пройшло не дуже добре але
нічого страшного скоро тут
проїжджатимуть інші
військові Уявіть собі що ви живете в
прекрасному регіоні але до лікаря можете
потрапити лише раз на два тижні немає
Ані лікарні Ані поліклініки Ані
медичного персоналу це особливо критично
у випадку коли потрібна невідкладна
медична допомога або Дини є хронічна
хвороба що ж для багатьох хорватів які
живуть на одному з численних островів це
реальність дедалі більше лікарів
виїжджають з країни в пошуках більш
високооплачуваної роботи за кордоном і
тому саме їхні колеги такі як Іван
стегіч беруть на себе тягар піклування
про пацієнтів які живуть далеко від
великих міст і
материка Ми зустрічаємося із доктором
Іваном
стегічем він лікує пацієнтів на
архіпелазі біля узбережжя шибеника
Хорватія після 50тихвилинної переправи
на поромі він потрапить на острів капріє
але він не знає що там на нього чекає
екстрена
ситуація у Хорватії понад 1000 островів
але лише на деяких є свій
лікар на менших островах у кращому
випадку є лише одна
медсестра там є
кисень вони дадуть вам балон
стегіч координує роботу медсестер на
сусідніх островах тому його телефон
постійно
розривається проблема в тому що в них
немає лікаря або Він приїжджає лише раз
на два тижні звісно цього недостатньо на
капріє живе близько 100 людей але зараз
разом з туристами їх близько 2 000 там
має бути лікар цілодобово принаймі
влітку у випадку надзвичайної ситуації
поліцейські катери можуть прибути за
півтори
що найстрашніше для вас
Діти коли трапляється надзвичайна
ситуація з маленькими дітьми їхнє життя
в
небезпеці ми прибуваємо у
капріє тут неймовірно красиво але стегіч
немає часу милуватися краєвидами трохи
вище по схилу пагорба на нього чекають
перші пацієнти
77річна рузанда караджолія з нетерпінням
чекає на
лікаря я стосовно мого чоловіка йому 91
рік у нього хворі і набряклі
ноги уже 5-шсть днів із ноги витікає
лімфатична
рідина де він зараз чи є
інфекція його ноги в жахливому
стані ви все
побачите доктор стегіч мусить поглянути
особисто він обіцяє поквапитися сепсис
може бути смертельним Але спершу його
допомоги потребують і інші мешканці
острова ця пацієнтка хоче обговорити
свої результати з лікарем але навіть Це
дається
нелегко лікар і медсестра чудові Слава
Богу але умови роботи
Ані інтернету Ані комп'ютера доводиться
писати від руки або користуватися
мобільним
телефоном мов у кам'яному
віці не лише обладнання залишає бажати
кращого багато хорватських лікарів
просто більше не хочуть Виконувати свою
роботу лікарів мало тому що багато хто
виїжджає вони їдуть за кордон за грошима
за кар'єрою Ну що там
ще
за кордоном можна заробити набагато
більше
грошей молодих лікарів це
спокушає тільки за перше півріччя 2023
року із Хорватії виїхав 91
лікар літні пацієнти на острові
потребують кращої медичної допомоги Не
кажучи вже про 2000 туристів
улітку
чесно кажучи ми навіть не думали про
медичні центри на випадок надзвичайних
ситуацій перед тим як їхати сюди Я
завжди перевіряю стан здоров'я
самостійно а тут пройде мабуть кілька
годин перш ніж вони приїдуть Якщо нам
знадобиться
допомога місцевих жителів особливо
турбує питання надзвичайних ситуацій Ну
що тут зробиш якщо не пощастило То ти
пропав тут немає грошей на гелікоптери
тільки в дубровнику вони краще
зекономлять якщо справа стосуватиметься
нас доктор стегіч їде до чоловіка
розанди
караджолі його родичі з нетерпінням
чекають на лікаря вдома але те що він
там застає справді викликає
тривогу то моти кидати тоти умерла
нога вам треба її
ампутувати ваша нога мертва вам потрібно
як швидше звернутися до судинного
хірурга вона дійсно мертва бактерії
можуть дістатися аж
сюди а відчуваєте
запах вам треба сісти на найближчий
човен до міста негайно не можна гаяти
часу але пацієнт відмовляється його
Сім'я повністю розгублена Вони хотіли б
щоб поруч був лікар на допомогу якого
можна було б
розраховувати стегічу час повертатися на
материк де на нього чекають інші
пацієнти він повернеться лише за два
тижні якщо він не поїде в лікарню бо не
хоче Що станеться у найгіршому випадку у
нього буде
сепсис потім він
помре невідомо чи зустрінуться вони
знову
це важка робота його попередник
звільнився Всього за місяць що
стосується доктора стегі жителі капріє
сподіваються що він протримається трохи
довше
є знову опинився в Епіцентрі серйозних
міграційних суперечок візовий скандал
сколихнув країну-члена ЄС Польщу
офіційно Країна має дуже суворе
міграційне законодавство Але через
гостру потребу у трудових мігрантах на
ринку праці нещодавно було видано сотні
тисяч робочих віз і нібито лише після
того як працівники посольства брали
хабаріід
заявників цей скандал має наслідки які
виходять далеко за межі
Польщі біля підніжжя Карпатських гір де
Словаччина зустрічається з Польщею
мандрівники зустрічаються з польськими
прикордонниками так не повинно бути
обидві країни входять до європейської
Шенгенської зони вільного пересування
але прикордонниця доро та кадзлка каже
що новий тимчасовий контроль допоможе
убезпечити
поляків із січня по вересень Минулого
року було зафіксовано 13 випадків
нелегальної міграції на цій ділянці
кордону цього року натомість таких
випадків було близько
160 зверніть увагу наскільки різко зріс
цей
показник Польща уже давно виступає проти
планів ЄС щодо більш рівномірного
розподілу мігрантів та біженців по всій
території блоку уряд пишається своїм
суворим підходом до іміграції а дорота
пишається тим що виконує його
накази Для мене велика честь носити цю
форму робота яку ми виконуємо допомагає
гарантувати безпеку як Шенгенської зони
так і Польської
держави але Імідж Польщі тепер може бути
під питанням після повідомлень про те що
сюди можна прискорено мігрувати за хабар
перші паростки скандалу були помічені
тут у Варшаві коли польські компанії які
відчувають неста кадрів у таких галузях
як будівництво транспорт і технології
попередили про порушення при отриманні
віз іноземними працівниками у таких
країнах як
Індія це було неможливо а потім вони
знайшли інформацію що є спосіб потрапити
на
прийом але Посередник просить 50 000
рупій щоб призначити зустріч у
польському
консульстві це було величезною проблемою
і перешкодою для розвитку польських
підприємств
полького
бізнесу цей працівник кухні з Непалу
якого ми будемо називати моханом також
добре знайомий із цією проблемою йому
нещодавно поновили дозвіл на роботу але
щоб потрапити сюди чоловіку довелося
отримати візу через посольство в Індії а
потім в Індії посольство не бере з нас
грошей але третя особа бере дуже багато
грошей і ми мусимо знаєте закладати наші
землі та інші речі в банк щоб отримати
гроші і заплатити
агентству допомогли вам потрапити на
прийом до посольства тактак після того
як вони отримують гроші вони допоможуть
подібні історії викликали бурю в ЗМІ
минулого місяця після раптового
звільнення міністра уряду журналісти
газети виборчої регулярно критикують
націоналістичний консервативний уряд
Польщі і вони швидко Почали перевіряти
джерела виявилося що в МЗС є Агенти цієї
антикорупційної поліції І що ми
дізналисяє є місця у світі в Африці та
Азії де тільки для того щоб отримати
польську візу щоб потрапити на прийом до
консульства потрібно заплатити 5 000
доларів хабара якомусь посереднику який
міг би про щось
домовитися це непрозора ситуація і
безумовно
корупція польський уряд відкидає
звинувачення у широкомасштабній змові
Влада визнає що деякі правопорушення
дійсно були ведеться розслідування понад
200 інцидентів кілька людей заарештовано
правляча партія заявляє що опозиція та
ЗМІ роздмухали із мухи
слона дійсно була група яка вирішила
розпочати злочинну діяльність беручи
хабарів в обмін на прискорення деяких
процедур жодна віза не була надана
нікому в обмін на
хабар не було ніяких порушень які б
стосувалися процедур
безпеки
наша прокуратура вже готує звинувачення
проти цих людей і вони мають бути
покарані новини про такі підозри вже
облетіли весь світ мігранти які
потрапляють до Польщі можуть легко сісти
на потяг і Вирушити до Німеччини або
багатьох інших частин ЄС завдяки
правилам вільного пересування і тому
офіційні особи блоку вимагають
ясності наприклад щодо кількості та
типів віз і консульських установ яких це
стосується а також місцезнаходження
власників віз ми також хочемо отримати
ясність щодо структурних заходів яких
вживає польська влада щоб забезпечити
захист системи від будь-якого можливого
шахрайства та корупційної
поведінки на словацькому кордоні такі
нові перевірки до вподоби місцевим якщо
вони упіймають кількох мігрантів
Протягом наступних кількох тижнів ми
знатимемо що це
дорота не ставить під сумнів план уряду
це служба це необхідність все більше і
більше віддаватися виконанню своїх
обов'язків але відповіді на питання про
масштаби цього скандалу ще
попереду для декого досі незрозуміло на
чию користь спрямована міграційна
політика цієї
країни Албанія стрімко стає одним із
найпопулярніших туристичних напрямків у
Європі привабивши цьогорічже 10 мльнів
відвідувачів національний парк що оточує
Дельту в йоси слугує домівкою для понад
200 видів птахів але зараз їхньому
середовищу існування загрожує
будівництво аеропорту мешканці
розриваються між бажанням зберегти
природу та потенційними економічними
вигодами які принесе збільшення
кількості
[музика]
туристів єдиною в своєму роді природний
рай у Європі дельта албанської річки
вюса ресторан барді трока знаходиться
прямо посеред неї щоб потрапити туди
відвідувачам доводиться перетинати
хиткий мотусковий міст звична справа для
барзі але для гостей ціла пригода
ресторан розташований на цьому
маленькому
острівці сезон вже закінчився
зараз найтихіша пара
року Лише кілька сусідів заходять
перекусити і поспілкуватися розмови
постійно зводяться до однієї теми
міжнародного аеропорту який планують
збудувати в цьому
районі Я бачу що це єдина можливість у
міжсезоння для нашого регіону
Ми дуже бідний
регіон аеропорт міг би нам
допомогти
і ми бачимо в цьому дуже хорошу
перспективу для орнітолога еральда ксеки
аеропорт - Це катастрофа частково Він
має бути побудований на території
природного заповідника пониззявйоси одна
з найбільших екосистем на Середземному
морі тут знаходять прихисток багато
видів птахів яким загрожує вимирання в
інших місцях тож це рай для орнітологів
зокрема еральда цікавить один
вид
Фламінго багато Фламінго
[музика]
Вау понад 2 000 птахів живуть тут і це
вражаюче природне
[музика]
видовище це місце відоме завдяки
птахам і воно дуже важливе для них тому
що служить місцем зимівлі годівлі
розмноження а також зупинки на
адріатичному шляху адже знаходиться
посередині шляху птахів що мігрують з
Північної Європи у південну і навіть
через море в
Африку за 5пть кмт звідси розгорнулося
величезне будівництво аеропорту одна
злітно-посадкова смуга буде завдовжки
понад 3 км Це буде Другий за величиною
аеропорт країни після аеропорту у
столиці тирані у навколо Дельти річки
вйоса одне із найулюбленіших туристичних
місць в Албанії аеропорт зробить цей
регіон більш доступним але екологи
кажуть що Будівництво почалося без
необхідних дозволів тому вони подали
скаргу Як бачите будівництво триває і з
нашої точки зору це повне
божевілля адже не можна будувати такий
аеропорт у заповідній
зоні са залишається однією з останніх
по-справжньому диких річок Європи
нещодавно уряд зробив велику заяву
оголосивши її верхів'я національним
парком не лише екологам Цікаво чому
нижню частину річки потрібно нищити
величезним
аеропортом насправді плани будівництва
цього аеропорту порушують екологічні
норми ЄС але ніхто не зізнається в цьому
на камеру компанія з якою укладено
контракт на будівництво аеропорту
відмовилась від інтерв'ю Міністерство
охорони навколишнього середовища в
тирані відкидає
звинувачення дослідження та стратегічне
екологічна оцінка проведені для
аеропорту в льора показали що він не
лише відповідає вимогам національного
законодавства Албанії але й міжнародному
законодавству щодо будівництва
аеропортів і захисту заповідників
барді трока каже що людям тут насамперед
потрібні робочі
місця він і його сім'я ледве зводять
кінці з кінцями проте іноді коли він
думає про аеропорт йому стає трохи не по
собі Зараз ми можемо не бачити ризиків
тому що зосереджені на позитивних
аспектах єдина реальна небезпека полягає
в тому що вони можуть зовсім вигнати нас
звідси його сусіди поділяють Змішані
почуття чоловіка ходять чутки про нові
величезні житлові комплекси вони
однозначно мають продовжувати будувати
аеропорт тому що це те що допоможе
країні і цьому регіону
розвиватися інфраструктура дороги Ну і
так далі нехай будують але тільки не за
рахунок знищення природи і тієї краси
яку ми тут маємо дерев і
моря природний Рай вйоса оточують Надії
мрії та
[музика]
страхи
є багато причин чому плюшеві ведмедики
найкращі друзі дітей Вони м'які і
приємні вони не відбирають Іграшки І до
того ж чудові слухачі
Дейві з Британії знає що з часом близькі
стосунки між плюшевим ведмедиком і
дитиною залишають свої сліди саме тому
вона відкрила спеціальну клініку для
плюшевих ведмедиків які втратили лапу чи
пошкодились
Це мабуть подарує ведмедику іще 60 років
а на цьому Ми завершуємо тижневий випуск
Європа У фокусі раді що ви приєдналися
до нас сьогодні з вами була лісшу до
наступної
[музика]
зустрічі
foreign